audio channel selector
floor
selection franchise
please
in the meantime we can test the
connection of mr borel please press the
speak button yes
hello how are you today
hi good afternoon uh i can hear you and
i can see you
okay
please remember about the selection of
the language
we see that in the audio channel
uh yes
we'll do
probably choose english
okay and then we're ready
uh okay and do
can you connect a microphone to this uh
computer that you're using
um this is the mic that the computer
no this is the microwave you should be
able to connect the table top microphone
would you say you hear me well
it would be better with a microphone but
if you don't know me uh then
it will have to work like this thank you
so much
good evening
can we kick off i'm asking brussels yes
chair we can see you and we can hear you
here in brussels
okay
i would like to begin our joint session
of effort and cedar
item number one if there are no
objections i propose to adopt the agenda
item number two chairs announcements let
me inform you that this extraordinary
meeting is being web streamed
for our meeting we have a reduced
language regime for interpretation
namely english french german and
ukrainian
let me also stress that it is mandatory
for members physically present in
meetings to wear a mask at all times
except
colleagues
i would like to thank our vice president
and high representative joseph burrell
for attending our meeting at short
notice a warm welcome to you jose
i would also like to welcome and thank
our colleagues from the vahof narada
for their readiness to discuss with us
in such a dire and dramatic situation
today is a very dark day for europe and
the entire world
president putin's decision to attack
and invade ukraine is totally
unjustified condemnable and reckless
it has already cost numerous lives
and the torah will
undoubtedly be much higher in the coming
days
a sovereign democratic european state is
under attack
by an autocratic and democratic regime
we simply cannot stand idle in front of
that
natalie lazor
and i decided to call this urgent
extraordinary meeting to assess the
situation with our vice president and
high representative
and also to listen to our ukrainian
colleagues urgent call on what is
necessary to address this situation
and express
our support
russia's flagrant disregard for the
international law demands a severe
response from the international
community
earlier this week several international
colleagues and myself condemned the
decision by the russian president
and parliament to recognize herself
proclaimed republics occupying areas of
the donetsk and
oblasts of ukraine as independent
entities and to send russian troops into
these territories
that decision was itself an obvious and
extremely serious violation of
international law and has led to the
termination of the mints agreements by
russia
today's events went way beyond that and
undisputedly proved that the russian
federation is unable to keep its word on
the international arena and is standing
in the way of the peaceful
resolution
of the conflict
i welcome the sanctions adopted by the
european union and our international
partners earlier this week which in the
light of the latest developments are to
be updated
and enforced
sadly we have to conclude that all the
sanctions we had in place so far
didn't deter the russian aggression
against ukraine hence now more than ever
we need to make sure that the ones that
will be adopted in the next hours
will work
sure enough we need to prepare swiftly
and comprehensively for
the effects of those sanctions on our
economies
but we need to understand that the
ongoing attack on ukraine is an attack
on peace an attack on democracy
and attack on all our most sacred values
and we cannot compromise on those
needless to say we need to explore all
possible ways to support ukraine
a detailed request list has been made by
ukraine to the eu institutions
and also to nato
those requests need to be addressed
quickly in the meantime it is clear that
the current crisis already had a
disastrous impact on the ukrainian
economy
and the war will only make it bigger
like many colleagues i welcome the 1.2
billion euros micro financial
package approved by the european
parliament and the council
but i think it will be hardly sufficient
to keep ukraine's economy afloat for
long
so i urge the eu institutions to prepare
immediately
an additional assistance plan
in parallel we need to prepare for the
humanitarian consequences of this
conflict this war which will be
particularly evident along our eastern
borders of the european union
before i give a floor to joseph burrell
and to our ukrainian colleagues i will
now give the floor to miss natalie wazzo
chair of our subcommittee on security
and defense for her introductory remarks
natalie the floor is yours
mercy david
mercier thank you very much david and
thank you joseph burrell for being with
us today uh thank you colleagues and
particularly the colleagues from the
behalf rada
i'll try and keep it brief i'll try and
give more space to the debate
but primarily
given the emotions that we're all
feeling today to see
ukraine
attacked aggressively militarily
i think that uh
i mean david mcallister will
feel the same as me that we were there
so recently
now for
the uh for
vladimir putin he actually sees ukraine
accurately as a democratic country that
is turned towards europe and that's
precisely why he wants to punish ukraine
this is a war
against everything that we are it's a
war against us therefore and we have to
be prepared to
confront this war
i wanted to ask you about what we can do
to help
of ukraine when fighting against cyber
attacks
i would also like to know what we can do
to protect ourselves from cyber attacks
which i'm sure they're coming our way in
europe too
i was wondering how stratcom is
mobilized to try and uh smoke out
russian disinformation and
respond to it
we need strategic communication from
europe
in russia in ukrainian to defend our
positions and to explain the reality
which is very different from the version
of reality that is uh being presented by
president putin
well what can we do to help ukraine
satellite images could be shared with
kiev for example the european peace
facility could be mobilized to a greater
extent
the euem ukraine mission
particularly its uh
uh
part in mario paul which was active just
a few days ago
thank you dear natalie was all for your
introductory remarks and now i
immediately hand over to the vice
president and high representative diego
zeparell thank you once again for
attending our meeting the floor is yours
for 10 minutes
thank you thank you to all of you
members of the parliament and david the
natalie
what we are witnessing since this
morning
since early this morning
are certainly
the darkest hour of our continent
at the worst moment since the end of the
world war ii
what we are witnessing
is that a
nuclear arm
power
has launched an unprovoked
large-scale invasion of a neighbor
of a democratic neighbor
ukraine which is a free and sovereign
country
and at the same time is threatening
everyone
who
is
trying to help them with a nuclear
retaliation
i know that there are ukrainian members
of the
of the parliament also present
and i give them a war welcome
to this house
what we thought
was unimaginable for us europeans
couldn't imagine that the war was coming
back to european borders
it was unthinkable
it's happening
it's happening in this century
and it's
affecting
people innocent people innocent
civilians
which are
feeling for their lives
and russia's aggressor
and we condemn this attack unjustified
in barbaric attack
and the cynical argument used to justify
the unjustifiable
way the european union by several voices
president of the commission president of
the european council myself
members of the parliament we condemn
in the strongest possible term they can
provoke invasion by armed forces of the
russian federation
and also the involvement of belarus in
this aggression
and called
both
obligations
we demand president putin to cease these
russian military operations immediately
and to withdraw their forces
from the entire territory of your brain
russia beerus bears responsibility full
responsibility for this act of
aggression
and all the destructions and losses of
lives
at this causing and they will cause
unhappily still more
we have already some month here the
russian ambassador
has have done many of our member states
in their respective capitals
we are also conducting the marches in
third countries worldwide
we are
appropriated
together with partners with whom we have
been coordinating so closely
we have to repeat once and again that
this attack against ukraine
is a flagrant violation of international
law and the core principles on which the
international rules based order is built
and the fact is that this invasion
started while the united nations
security council was in session about
exactly the issue
it's another proof of russia blatant
disregard for international law and
institutions as well as the rule
invasion international order such as the
united nations charter
the helsinki final act of the charter of
paris
it's also a violation of the basic
principle of human coexistence
i am a little bit uh
tired of repeating that once and again
in all four
but it's important that we continue
stressing
that this violation caused lives
as unknown sequences for the world
because now we are turning a page in the
history of evil
in a dangerous path
we together with our transatlantic
allied mind partners
have been united in making unprecedented
efforts to achieve the probative
solution to the security crisis caused
by russia
but russia has not reciprocated his
efforts and instead opted unilaterally
for a grave and premeditated escalation
you have made clear
from the outset
and at the highest political level that
any further military aggression against
ukraine will have major consequences and
severe cost i am also
a little bit tired repeating these once
and again
saying that this is going to have
massive consequences in severe cause and
the moment has come to prove that it's
true
and that's why we are responding
in the strong impossible terms
president michel has called for a
meeting with the european council this
evening
and the country will discuss and agree
and provide political guidance
to adopt this package which has been
worked on
by my services and by the service
commission
and being presented tomorrow on the
frank office council for its approval
because as you know
sanctions
well sanctions the word sanctions it
doesn't appear in the treaty we talk
about coercive measures
the adoption of question measures
is a competence of the council and
that's what the concert will do tomorrow
this sciences will respond will include
both sectoral individual restrictive
measures individual and sectoral
measures
they have been built in coordination
with our transatlantic and like-minded
partners
and all of us the man international the
international community demand russia
for the immediate end of this
aggression and we also call russia to
ensure the safety of the aussie special
monitoring missions
and i think that the role of the
european parliament is pressing a strong
support to ukraine and condemnation to
russian invasion as a particular
importance
i've been asking about
how to fight this information one of the
most important things that we have to do
because you cannot imagine
how strong is the this information that
russia's pouring for its media
because putin wants not only to conquer
the
land
but also the spirit
and our
strategy come for the eastern
part of europe is doing a great job on
dubuquing
the local identifying and presenting the
alternative
ways and means of explaining what's
happening there because the russian
propaganda is blaming the west
presenting ukraine
as a real threat and claiming that it's
all our fault
ukraine is not threatening
russia
military
ukraine represents a threat to russia
because
the democratic development
of ukraine can represent really a threat
because it's a kind of a mirror for the
russian society
submitted to a strong authoritarian
regime
and if ukraine continues developing
according
with
democracy political democracy and free
economy
then it will prove that the way
russia is behaving
is against the interest of the russian
people because they are providing no
welfare
no freedom
so stratcom will continue working on
that
it's uh
everyday work
they have a lot of means
and we have to continue facing this
avalanche of this information
and also you ask me about how i'm going
to support ukraine
well this is the moment to express our
support both politically financial
and also providing humanitarian
assistance
we are mobilizing all our efforts
we have recently a macro financial
assistance package of 1.2 billions
the
natalie was asking about how to mobilize
european peace facility recently we
provided 36 million euros to increase
the logistic capacity of the ukrainian
army
we decided and maybe too late but it's
there to launch a mission for military
training at highest level for the
ukrainian army
but i think that the support that
ukraine needs
has no room inside of the current
financial
capacities
of the current budget
if we want to support ukraine
financially we need much more
and on the same way that to face the
pandemic
we break the taboos and we went into new
encourages and
strong
new tools and methods with the new
generations and
and the collective debt
if you want to give ukraine the support
he deserves and he needs
is not grasping here and there in the
budget lines of millions years and
millions there in order to
build a new package
the amount of need is much bigger than
that we will need the newest financial
instruments and new
financial contributions from member
states
if we really want to have ukraine
we need to be serious and to be acting
at the same level of the challenge that
this russian aggression implies
we are not a military union we're not a
military force
so
when you ask me about uh
suppose this thing that is not the
european union who can do
for example we don't support
sending off but some member states are
doing some members has been doing they
will continue doing
among those packages that we will
we already approve a package took a days
ago
the reason in addition to that that you
know the germans or the government
to stop the working well not to stop the
working because it has not still
started working and more stream too is
still on the validation process to stop
this validation process
which i think is a good news in order to
make russia understand
that our dependency from the gas will
come to an end
as soon as possible and this is one of
the most important challenges for us
today on the prospects of the green
deal but also on the prospects of our
strategic autonomy
we need to reduce our dependency on
russian gas
russian about 50 of our gas consumption
in europe
it's too much
we have to reduce this
we are ready to face
any reduction in gas supply
but uh structurally we have to take
measures technological and financial
measures in order to look for
alternative sources of energy renewables
and hydrogen and this is one of the
consequences that we had to take a
lesson that we had to take from the
ukrainian crisis and i don't know how to
call it ukrainian crisis i want to call
it a russian crisis
the most important thing together is to
issue as he was saying the foreign
effort is to retain
to insure
the survival of ukraine
a roughly independent country
with the integrity of his territory
inside the internationally recognized
borders
and this is what we have to focus on
but also
to understand that with the current
regime with the party government in
government
is not going to be possible to have
agreements that allow us to cooperate
with russia but we want to cooperate
with the russian people
one thing is a kremlin put in regime
another thing is the russian people with
whom we want to have
the better relation of friendship and
cooperation
but today we are facing a war just that
a war
something that was imaginable
that is out of our
mindset
because we refuse we reject
we abandon war as a way of solving
differences and conflicts between people
and countries
but in spite of us in spite of our will
the war
has come back
and is showing its face in our borders
some month ago when he presented the
strategic compass
he presented
it saying that europe is in danger
and some
maybe some of you
believe that it was trying to
create fear among people in order to
sell my product
well no
now maybe you are everybody will be much
more much more aware of why i was saying
and i am still saying illusion danger
not just from the eastern borders we
have other problems but today mainly in
the eastern border because this is going
to change the pace of history
not only for europe but the whole
mankind
this has to be looked with a broader
lens
understanding what russia represents
today
what it's alliance with china with it
may represent today
in this fight between democracies and
authoritarian capitalism
this is maybe the most important
challenges that we are going to face in
the coming days coming years more
because this crisis
is not going to be solved overnight
it's an existential threat to ukraine
but also for us the european union
something that they put in russia don't
like at all because we represent just
the contrary of what they do represent
and then that fight this political fight
european parliament
is being called to play an important
role because you are the political
representation of the european people
thank you
thank you very much dear zepharel
for your statement and i would fully
like to subscribe
to what we've just heard
colleagues
we
have invited
to connect digitally
our ukrainian colleagues
in these
very very difficult dark hours
so i would like to give the floor now
first to the chair of the european
integration committee of the vahof
narada
ivana klimpush sinzatsa
ventiva chair of the hofner rada's
committee on foreign policy mr alexander
mireshko and finally to the co-chair
of our parliamentary association
committee mr vadim
shook
please you have the floor together
perhaps you can limit each other all of
you to about two to three minutes first
ivana please
thank you thank you cheer thank you
honorable colleagues
uh
we all woke up this morning at five
o'clock in the morning i probably will
be a bit emotional at five o'clock in
the morning to the blasts and sellings
that we hurt nearby
our homes
and we believed
as a good neighbor the eu would probably
by 6 00 a.m or by 7 a.m would have those
sanctions that have been pre-agreed
already immediately released upon russia
but that is not happening 15 hours since
then we are still waiting for the
decision to be taken we're waiting for
the decision to be taken and we are
hearing that such countries as germany
cyprus hungary italy are doubting
whether um russia could be cut off swift
i think um
all those who are not
lining up with ukraine with a clear
action not message not words not support
not con condemnation but a real real
action against russian federation
against aggressor that has been lying to
the whole world and that has been is
that is killing today
our our citizens our kids that is
attacking our airports that is attacking
our cities our villages
that is threatening our children um
he has to be pushed back and we thought
that that would be happening not only by
ukrainians in a blink of an eye but also
by our partners and i'm calling on each
and every one of you who care who um
met ukrainians who know
how ukrainians do cherish
human rights democracy freedoms that we
were fighting for for all these eight
years uh to actually stand up and call
on your governments to immediately
release sanctions against uh russian
federation that would stop putin because
the previous package and i appreciate
the previous package that was passed a
couple of days ago
didn't do anything you see that he
doesn't care this kremlin dwarf that is
attacking not us exclusively he is
attacking the whole world um
as for the information we have
is that their plans for tonight our
encirclement of cave are attacking on
center of cave are attacking also on uh
all the governmental uh bodies and um
authorities
thus to change the um
the cave uh freely elected government
and authorities to someone uh some
puppets that will follow through with
the with the um
agenda and demands of the russian
federation i do trust you colleagues
will not allow that to happen i do trust
you colleagues will take action and i
think the least you could do at this
point a this devastating sanctions on
russia uh released right now with swift
with um embargo and russian oil and gas
being uh being bought with um you know
you can you can go further with banking
with banking systems of visa and
mastercard i know it's not it's not
governed by the eu but you probably can
also reach out to your colleagues in the
um in the us uh being um
prohibited for russians to be to be used
it's not it's not putin himself who is
killing our people today it's russian
people who are coming under his command
killing our ukrainian uh compatriots uh
i think we have to fully isolate russia
from any possible international uh
contact that he is aspiring to have i
think
full-fledged uh
supply of weapons to ukraine with the
modern military capability every nation
can take the the action and i know that
it's not about the eu to decide this but
i'm calling on your nations to do that
financial assistance 1.2 billion
definitely was a very great and
important
message and and very important move that
you have taken we highly appreciate that
but i think uh there is more to come if
we want ukraine to survive and if we
want the whole the whole europe
that the whole europe would not fall as
a domino because of the russian attack
uh of ukraine on ukraine which would uh
which would be falling so i am calling
on your consciousness
uh colleagues i'm calling on your
activity i'm calling on your engagement
i'm um
hoping that you are politicians with
values and we are not going to see
trade-in again values for money
and definitely not in your house thank
you
thank you
now give the floor to alexander mareshbo
please
ah thank you dear colleagues can you
hear me
can you hear me
yes we can hear you but i'm not sure
thank you see you but please
unfortunately i also cannot see you but
i'll try to be really quick because uh
truly time is of essence
uh we members of ukrainian parliament we
don't know what will happen next where
we'll be in few days whether we'll still
be alive or not and uh the time has come
to to say the most important words in
attempt to persuade you because uh at
stake is survival of our nation and of
our country
we need
to do something
uh serious and important to stop putin
to stop russian aggression we need quick
and effective sanctions which would be
effective enough to stop him
uh i'll try uh to list very quickly what
we need first of all we need to totally
politically and diplomatically isolate
the aggressor second we need to switch
off swift and i'm surprised to hear and
to read that some countries i'm not
going to name them but some countries
in the european europe union are against
this idea we need non-fly zone because
russian aircraft military aircraft
is moving to kiev we also need uh you to
start freezing russian assets and
russian property so basically we need
very radical steps which will stop putin
uh time for words is over now the time
for actions has come and i i agree with
my colleague
ivana she says that we shouldn't
distinguish between putin and russian
people
unfortunately putin was elected
democratically and russian people
support him that's why this sanctions
should be felt by all russian people by
each russian citizen thank you
thank you dear alexander
and now i give the floor to vadim
shook please
thank you dear colleagues indeed i'll be
very brief
my colleagues have
described very well
what it is
that we need from you
that we expect from you and we
beg
you to act very quickly
uh
the whole
european integration
idea
of ukraine is now is is very much
at stake
in terms of people being extremely
worried
about the way it's going it's extremely
important that you start speaking with
on boys
and if possible please
use all the influence you have on those
countries that were named that are
blocking this what we believe would be
very painful very serious uh
mechanism turning russia from swift
uh i only start very shortly on one more
measure that my colleagues did not
mention i believe introduction of no fly
zone over ukraine
that is that one's extremely important
and uh should have been should have been
done
early early on today when we were woken
up by explosions
when we were talking uh the
last time we met here in cave i believe
we were discussing different topics
including the topic of whether we can
fight russia well i think we have
demonstrated for today how prey for our
soldiers are
how effectively we can use the weapons
that we grateful for to our allies that
were supplies however the superiority in
the air
is something that it is difficult for us
to fight with so that one is extremely
important that one uh we are sure will
change the way things are being played
out in ukraine
thank you for giving us the floor
thank you vadim thank you to all
free
colleagues
partners and friends
from the ukrainian vehicle
i now give the floor to the chairman of
our parliamentary delegation to the eu
ukraine parliamentary association
committee vetoed vashikovsky for two
minutes we told please
yes good evening everyone thank you
david and greetings for our colleagues
and friends in in ukraine staff of
ukraine
um these are really dark
days and i have a bitter unsatisfaction
because for a number of years for more
than 20 years
we're warning our colleagues a lot
around europe about the signals negative
signals coming from
from russian government shelley from
putin
about churchill above the munich
conference and he speaks 2007
georgia crimea donbass
recently when he was
crossing out of contemporary
architecture in europe
for 20 years we were exercising at his
management and
illusions
we need a dual approach first
we have to condem and penalize uh
russia and number of issues were
mentioned as the proposals
economic sanction
personal sanctions but also some
symbolic
but drastic sound should exclude
russians from
prestigious performance uh
culture scientific sports events like
champions league eurovision context so
on so forth they're supposed to be
authorized and isolate
isolated parallel to this we supposed to
provide a
positive positive perspective for
ukrainians membership in european
membership action
bring them closer to 3c initiative
sectoral
policy agencies of the european union
single market
and others additional financial
assistance of course is very
much needed
we need
we supposed to give them also the [ __ ]
to defend themselves and we supposed to
reorient our policy in european union to
allow us to defend them to defend
ourselves
before i think that before we we are
going to be killed by
a smoke made of burning coal
we can be killed by iskandar missile
launch from
kaliningrad region thank you
thank you dear beatholt
and now we come to the intervention of
our members i will give the floor to the
members appearing the speakers list for
two minutes each and we start with our
standing repertoire on ukraine mihir
gala
mr gallo you have the floor please press
the space button
[Music]
yeah
dear colleagues please
no i haven't no
that doesn't work
michael we will get back to you
after the next speaker so can i now give
the floor to our stunning repertoire on
russia
andreas cabellius
yeah thanks uh david and thanks
colleagues and especially ukrainian
colleagues
yeah so
difficult days
and all the support from our side all
the
wishes of of uh
you know security and
and at the end you know victory
uh i have here just few comments you
know to say uh definitely you know what
putin started
to do this morning it's international
crime and we need to talk
very very close very clearly now you
should be in
at the end he will end in international
tribunal together with lukashank
uh second ukraine is defending itself we
are getting you know
uh the last information uh is defending
in a difficult battles
some you know places are occupied like
chernobyl nuclear power plant by russian
you know troops which is now not very
clear what what does it mean and what
can happen
but ukrainians are defending in a very
successful way using those weapons which
we you know were able to provide at
least some countries
and as we hear from ukrainians you know
some of uh military helicopters russian
military helicopters or tanks were hit
by
uh stingers or javelins which were
provided by lithuania by other european
or american you know or
or british authorities on sanctions
definitely we need to be very
very strict very you know
clear united
but we should not
hope that sanctions will stop
immediately you know putin because i see
his actions as actions of madman so
embargo on oil and gas
imports to europe needs to be
implemented immediately because this
dependency is very dangerous for europe
itself you know and and putin will use
that at some time so we need to cut by
ourselves of course swift is very
important technologies are also very
important not to provide any more you
know
russia with modern technologies
processors i.t software and maybe we can
use possibilities that some of military
equipment is using you know western
uh itie programs and and we can try to
use that dependency on on those i.t
services no cutting exam of service
supply
we need to be strong thank you
andrews it's two minutes each okay good
i stop yeah
thank you andreas and now i'll go back
to mikhail gala for two minutes
chair mr gala is not connected
so obviously
there's still technical difficulties
for michelle
then i will now give the floor to
representatives of the political groups
two minutes each and we begin with the
epp group i'm calling sheliana zofco
my dear colleagues
what we have feared has happened
we can hear you but we can't see you the
screen is dark
can you turn on your screen
i'm just trying to i'm sorry
um
i'm sorry
okay just take me a few minutes to fix
it sorry they will get back to you too
sven mixer for the s d group please
cheer mr galler is back
dear with the chair mr geller is back
online okay ben i'm now calling michael
gala it is here
yes thank you very much dear colleagues
dear friends that i started this day and
my thoughts are with you
and
i think what we can deliver today
is hopefully
that
we push our governments in the european
council today tonight that they really
pass an ambitious
an ambitious package of sanctions
ambitious in the sense that everything
that is on the table is also done
because russia
the
dictator in the kremlin uses also
everything that he has got to
to to uh to get ukraine on its knees
and
accordingly
we need to take all measures that we
have got at our disposal and i am very
clear on that although i am aware there
is resistance to that also from my own
country germany uh to to impose swift i
think that is an essential tool uh to
impress on putin i think on our american
friends they can cancel or stop the
american express visa and
mastercard axes for russian users so
that every russian citizen who has these
things is
aware that something wrong is ongoing
and all the other
specific instruments that have been
named and i think perhaps to add uh
closing the airspace for russian uh
aircraft
for russian airlines like like aerofraud
they should not have a right to land in
the european union and beyond so these
are things that would really hopefully
uh
impress on putin and in parallel all our
solidarity will go in the humanitarian
field i think there are already
ukrainians probably arriving on our
borders and we should take them in and
not uh
and show our solidarity and as i just
heard from ivana she informed that
channel bill has unfortunately been
taken by the russians
that is also
bad news because how they care for such
sensitive things we are aware
and so far
let us work tonight for a good outcome
of our sanctions list and
stay with you and pray with you
slavokraini
thank you very much mihir gala
for these
very warm words
juliana for the epp
right
in this very difficult moment for europe
and for the whole world
i just wish to join with the
condemnation russian action
and the action of mr putin and to ask
for unity of european union in
introducing sanctions
croatia knows very well what it means to
be left alone
when faced with the aggression
and i hope that the
european union will follow the example
of croatia
that will show all solidarity with
ukrainian people
and that
ukrainian people faced with
goliath will not suffer as much as we
did
i think that the
public relation
war has already been lost by mr putin
and i feel really sorry for all the
confusion that russian people
are facing with this
attack on their consciousness
at this moment in full solidarity with
ukraine thank you
thank you dearly nazoko
i am now calling sven mixer for the
smd mr mixo please press on this big
button thank you
yes uh thank you very much david uh i
agree with all the previous speakers
that that we should uh release the
sanctions and we shouldn't hold anything
back at this moment
i believe that obviously we need to
inflict serious pain and putin and this
inner circle but i also agree with the
president of the of the commission
madame van der lyon who said that that
we should
seek to weaken russian economy and its
industrial base so as to make sure that
it doesn't have in the future the
strength to affect international peace
and security in the way that he has
demonstrated he is he's ready and
capable of doing at this moment
secondly i believe we we should do
everything to boost our own resilience
and enhance our deterrent posture
against the future russian aggressive
steps uh obviously this is more a job
for for the nato alliance but security
is indivisible and we should see what we
as european union can do in this respect
and third i also agree with high
representative that when we are doing
what we can to help ukraine uh to to
maintain its independence independent
statehood and and and and boost its uh
defenses and we should think out of the
box and not just resort to the existing
instruments but look for new instruments
that would match the scale of the
challenge thank you very much
thank you mr mixer
i am now
calling petrus ostravichos for the renew
group petras please
mr sure is not connected
okay petra's astoria says
is not connected then i give the floor
to reinhardt
for the greens
thank you
chair
i want to thank joseph porrell first of
all
who said that this is indeed
the darkest hour since the end of the
second world war
for his
strong efforts
to build a united front
because
we all understand that in this situation
europe can only be successful if we
overcome our divisions and stand
together
since this morning we're living in a new
era
we will have to learn that russia has
been turned into
a revisionist neighbor with imperial
ambitions
that will challenge many assumptions
that we had thought
well founded
i am as all the other colleagues in
favor of the toughest possible sanctions
package
in order to weaken the russian economy
and to limit the possibility for
the russian dictator to mobilize
financial resources
we also should focus on necessary
humanitarian
support this will not be a short-term
challenge
not for the ukrainian people and not for
the rest of europe
we will have to isolate russia we will
have to
turn putin into an international pariah
but we also have to deal with
certain
ways of elite capture that russia has
successfully employed within the
european union
and finally
i want to acknowledge
that in russia
some very courageous citizens
democrats
have demonstrated against the war
there also our european brothers and
sisters
thank you the iran had gucci coffer
now for the id group i give the floor to
ms von frisco
miss van frisco could you please press
on the speak button thank you
thank you mr chair
dear mr burrell good afternoon
and the dear colleagues of european
parliament
and the ukraine's parliament
it's in time like this that we value
as europeans
our long-term strategic partnership
shared values and economic systems with
allies and the like-minded partners
and i want to be clear
natto needs a strong and capable
european defense
not just in the east
or in the south
everywhere
and today more than ever
this violation of international law has
become
incontrovertible proof
of russia's foreign policy toolbox
asymmetric threats
this is the russian way of corroding
endangering and threatening
the rule-based international order
but we will not intermediate
and together we will do
whatever it takes to preserve ukraine's
sovereignty
europe's security
and the integrity of international order
based on the rules and values we share
with friends and partners
thank you
thank you miss von frisco
for the ecr group anna fortiga two
minutes please
thank you chair dear ukrainian friends
high rep vice president
today we are here first and foremost to
express solidarity to you
dear friends and to to whole ukrainian
nation i must admit that
despite
decades of of my work early warnings
all efforts i i feel this bitters taste
today
and i remember that in his recent
speeches
vadimir putin actually threatened the
whole western world and we have to to
know that ukraine is not a part of
russian uh
mere
russian order
but it is part of this collective war uh
west and by defending ukraine we defend
ourselves all of us not only values
but now now threats are very real and
most probably
we have to face
costs of of actions
costs of
actions that are certainly late because
we should have been
much more resolute much earlier
than today so today their high rep vice
president sanctions sanctioned sanctions
lists of
sanctions were already presented they
are well known i of course
support all of this and i i put
stress on
diplomatic isolation
russia under putin is a rock state
an aggressor
and and
it should be end to
to to
an ungrounded
dialogue actually willing simply to to
engage mingle with with the
kgb regime thank you
thank you anna fourtega i have been
informed that for a new group hill
developments would like to take the
floor instead of petra's australis
dear hilda you have the floor
mr advanced please press the button
good evening dear mr burrell dear
members of the ukrainian parliament dear
colleagues allow me to express my
support to our ukraine colleagues and
ukraine people who are now under attack
i was very much touched
by your testimonials and i can feel what
you feel i feel the fear even here
people in my country are feared
and fear for the war so i really
want you to know that we support you and
all the people
over there it's absurd that in 2022 we
have a war at the european continent
and and i think the colleagues told
already a lot that we have to support
the sanctioned regime mr burrell that
you will discuss this evening the firm
sanctioned regime but i'm also very
worried about what we can do i'm very
worried about the unity of europe i
think
about the discussions of the sanctions
europe was well really united but what i
now really need is that we stand united
also to look at the consequences of this
war to support the ukrainian people also
to look at what were the victims of this
war will europe be there to help to cure
them what will we do with the refugees
will we leave all the national countries
together to do that or will europe make
make a stand and do that together that's
really my question will you be united
to battle the consequences of this war i
also think we have to look because we
talk about sanctions against russia but
you know that putin will take sanctions
also towards europe towards other
countries we have to look at the sectors
who will pay that bill that's also a
question that i have for you to take
with you to this council meeting this
evening good luck the parliament will
support you be strong and keep europe
really united that's my message from
venue europe
thank you the developments
for the left i now give the floor to
mick wallace i'm calling brussels
thanks very much david
the tax on ukrainian targets and
incursions of russian forces into
ukraine are an act of aggression and a
serious violation of the un charter
they have
already resulted in loss of life
the pretext president putin is using to
justify his decision are contrary to
international law and cannot be
supported
russian arguments about its security
interest in the face of nato expansion
are valid and should be taken seriously
but they do not justify the decision
russia has now taken
we echo the call
of the un
secretary general antonio gutierrez the
conflict must stop now
the only legitimate forum for addressing
russia's actions
at an international level is united
nations
unilateral action from the u.s eu or
nato only raise further escalation
and no military solution
for what is now happening
there's
we have to oppose
all military
we oppose any military response just as
unequivocally as we oppose russia's
actions
russia must withdraw his troops from
ukraine immediately
seize all military operations and resume
diplomatic engagement all parties must
work to restore the minsk process as the
only path to a peaceful resolution of
the conflict
the responsibility for opening
hostilities is solely with president
putin
but we do not withdraw our long-standing
criticism of nato's brinksmanship and
recklessness
of western policy on ukraine
both russia and the west bear
responsibility for creating conditions
of instability and confrontation in
ukraine in pursuit of their strategic
and economic interest
despite rhetoric europe hasn't been a
friend of ukraine the country has been
used as a pawn and ukrainian lives have
been treated as expendable
it is the first duty of the european
anti-war movement to criticize the role
of european and allied governments in
fanning the flames of the conflict not
just governments over which it has
little influence
in the months to come it is all the more
important that this duty is upheld thank
you
thank you
for the none in screen i give the floor
to our colleague andrea
oscar
thank you very much uh chair
thank you for the floor and also for the
opportunity to speak at these hard times
unfortunately our greatest fear has
occurred
this morning russia has attacked ukraine
with military force and there is no
more peace in europe
the situation is very dangerous so we
must do everything we can to restore
peace as soon as possible
as you may remember i'm very much
interested in the happenings in ukraine
and i often raise my voice uh for the
transcapacity and hungarians
so now uh i also would like to express
my great worries about people who suffer
in this situation uh civilian people as
i have heard uh are scared and they're
hispanic in several places
so the eu must assure ukrainian people
that the borders of the eu will be open
for them therefore we must ensure that
they can count on us
they can count on the eu's
uh helping hand and also humanitarian ad
in order to survive in this
unprecedented situation
hungary as one of the closest neighbors
uh continues to stand for the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
ukraine it condemns all actions uh that
jeopardize it
and uh
that is why we supported the united
actions of the eu and nato
hungary has helped ukraine so far
in difficult times and is remain
ready to provide humanitarian assistance
to the country during these hard times
i also would like to condemn russia's
military action and hope everyone would
work on stabilizing the situation and
the escalating
the situation thank you very much
thank you
colleagues i would love to give the
floor to more of you i know that there
are many colleagues who would also like
to contribute but unfortunately we will
have to close our meeting soon
not only because we have a certain slot
also because
some of our guests as you notice are in
paris in the french parliament and the
preparatory meetings for the ipc
are now to begin but before i close the
meeting i want to give the floor back to
our ukrainian
colleagues
partners and friends
would you like to comment on what you've
heard
i'm asking the three colleagues who
already gave the floor but i've also
been informed that maria ionova or maria
metzen seva would like to take the floor
so please go ahead ukrainian colleagues
we want to listen also to your thoughts
colleagues thank you uh we appreciate
your support we appreciate you standing
by uh ukraine but again i would just
reiterate it's about accents today it's
not about words anymore
and uh um
quite a few of you have gone through
challenging experiences but only those
who have
hurt the
sirens in your cities only those who
have seen
killed children in the cities only those
who have
uh
who have heard the blasts of uh
cells
nearby probably
will understand what ukrainians across
the country feel at this particular
moment and i am
calling on every each
one of you to just take connection thank
you
thank you
maria ionova i see you're connected
mrs younever please press the space
button
can you hear me
can you hear me
yes i hear you
uh-huh thank you thank you so much yes
um probably i will be also emotional
because telling the truth when we every
minute during our meeting we are getting
news that
uh uh now is occupied they're going
they're moving to bergens and they would
like to uh surround um and they would
they will uh occupy the whole south
you know we really ask you for actions
because uh let me be clear because
probably uh next time you will not be
able to have to speak with
with us as uh there is a big probability
that key will be tomorrow surrounded
also that is why we're calling this is a
humanitarian uh catastrophe this says uh
regarding our infrastructure and the uh
atomic station
also i would like to just to say because
we've got calls from uh um front lines
that they attacks hospitals they attacks
children and they attacks wounded people
uh
they that is why you know we
we we do not know what how can we prove
that we are fighting
for all this european uh well use and we
are really asking you to stop at least
a ceasefire because the this uh uh you
know to to
uh react on more uh
adequates for for the reality as we have
also a lot of sabotage groups in kiev
and in ukraine which are also hunting
the politicians
and starting from 2014 and that is why
we know uh your capacity we know your
possibilities we just uh do not ask we
just ask you do not lost time it will be
late
and it's it's just it's not uh how to
say we are getting used every minute
every five minutes that situation is
uh very critical on humanitarian and on
military also with the special forces
and aviation uh
russian federation thank you
thank you dear colleague yolova
would somebody else from ukraine like to
take the floor
cheer mrs messen seba
is
asking for the floor
miss senseiva please
miss me please press on the speak button
good evening colleagues i hope you hear
me well my internet is not operating uh
um normally because i'm calling you from
the basement our building has been
evacuated uh to the basement quite
recently but i have heard all your
sincere supportive messages and i would
like to emphasize
uh knowing the fact that the list of
sanction has been drafted before and
it's a very strong
sectoral economic ones but several of
the important things i'd like to stress
on it's the banning of export and
re-export of raw materials and high-tech
machinery it's undertaken measures to
disconnect russian federations from
global financial system and my
colleagues spoke about swift please
press on the member state to do so it's
imposing sanctions and registration of
russian seaports in the sea of azov the
black sea it's imposing sanctions on the
remaining russian military industry
complex it's strategic it's it's
abandoning the expert of strategic goods
to the russian federation and they can
be used for military capabilities we do
know that prohibition on the supply of
european techno communication equipment
including micro electronics it does help
russian military to target
us
dear dear colleagues this is the very
decisive time this is the time to stand
up together not only for ukraine but the
democracy the human rights and values we
all share straight after the second
world war this union was not created to
the war it was created to do peace
please consider also the security in on
air the 5 a.m situation was not the tank
situation which reached actually harkev
partially the outskirts of kiev southern
part of her sun region northern part of
cherny give region and when i saw the
pictures on the social media from the
home place where i was growing up and
the tanks were cross in my garden there
were 30 russian tanks that was not a
joke please consider our emotions but
also cold thoughts and proposals high
appreciation for your time tonight and i
i wish you fruitful negotiations further
and peace to the whole subcontinent of
europe thank you dear colleagues from
all my heart
thank you
i can now conclude our meeting let me
first of all thank our french colleagues
who made it possible that the members of
the ipc were able to connect from the
french parliament in paris i would like
to thank all meps for their
contributions
i would like to thank the high
representative and vice president for
attending the first part of our meeting
before we had to leave for the european
council
and finally
wholeheartedly let me thank
our ukrainian colleagues for their
comments for their clear words for their
emotional words
in these extremely
difficult times we all know the
situation in ukraine
is extremely critical
and it is our duty to stand by our
ukrainian partners and friends
in this terrible moment
thank you
and i will now conclude the meeting
unless anyone would like to raise a
point under any other business
that is not the case
then also on behalf of natalie wazoo
i closed this joint alfred city meeting
you